[Musique]
numérique la qualité urbaine en question
pose la question de l'incidence du
numérique dans les pratiques que les
citadins ont de la ville et il s'agit de
comprendre quelles sont les conséquences
de nos usages du numérique sur notre
relation à la ville mais notre rapport
aux autres aussi dans le nez dans l'est
dans l'espace public urbain
globalement un une une centaine de pages
200 pages j'essaie de vous expliquer ce
qui a deux dans ce petit appareil et
surtout ce qu'il ya derrière pour
essayer de démystifier l'objet et puis
vous montrer que finalement même si la
vitrine est belle l'arrière boutique et
peut-être des fois un peu sombre
c'est un livre qui raconte l'histoire de
deux jeunes filles qui ont 17 ans elles
doivent partir en australie mais
malheureusement elle s'arrête en
slovénie dans une maison qui est un
petit peu particulière un petit peu
mystérieuse sur laquelle il ya un
terrain de fouilles archéologiques à
partir de ce moment là un nouveau monde
va s'ouvrir à ces deux adolescentes
qui parle de la protection des animaux
sauvages les différents problèmes qui
sont liés à l'homme et comment à hauteur
d'enfant on peut faire des actions qui
peuvent changer cette situation en tout
cas améliorer cette situation
[Musique]
une histoire d'anticipation qui part de
la montée des multinationales qui vont
décider de numériser l'ensemble des
livres de la planète
et brûlé tout ce qui est
du papier de manière à pouvoir avoir un
contrôle sur ce qui peut être lu par la
population